仏教の空っていうのは快楽や満足感が蓄積
にいつまで立っても空っぽのまま満たされ
ないっていう意味でリン廻転象っていうの
は生まれ変わりのことで生まれ変わっても
満足感は空っぽのまま得られないからこの
ように生まれ変わってくるなよ。りン廻
転職するなよっていうことを社は解いてい
ます。本来はネガティブ思想です。ト感な
クーリンネテンションの意味を解いてます
ね。間違えまくってるっていうコメントが
ありました
。お前が間違いまくっとるんやないか。
社迦がリン廻転職を解いたかね。シ迦の
言ってるリ廻転章は意味が全然違うで。
あんたの言ってるリ廻転象というのはあれ
はウパニシャド哲学シャ迦はウパニシャド
哲学を正しくしたんだ。あれは哲学であっ
て間違っとったんやね。だからリン廻天を
そういう意味生まれ変わって生まれ変わっ
てというような意味に解いた。だけど
お釈迦様はこういうこと言っとるんで本体
論だって言ったかな。永遠とか無永久そう
いうことについては考えることもならん、
議論することもならんって言ってるんや。
なぜならば人間の脳はそういうことを
考えることができるようにはできてない。
この3次元の有限の世界に生きとるで
出来上がったからやね。で、何べも言う
ように科学しか信用しないリ廻転象がそう
いう意味だと言うんなら証明できるのか?
あんたは前世では何やったんだ?原生では
生まれ変わって人間になったわけやろ。
来政はどうなるかわからん。前世は何だっ
たの?その記憶はあるんかな?あれはせん
やろ。というリ廻転職証明できんやないか
。我々はそれは非科学だからと思わない
。リン廻転章というのは訳後中国に入って
きた時に仏教がリ廻転章という言葉ができ
たわけよね。その前はパーリー語
サムサーラかそういう意味やで。
サムサーラの意味は彷徨うとかそういう
ような意味なんや。何が彷徨うの?理性が
彷徨う。
[音楽]
あるいはっていうね、それが彷徨うんだ。お釈迦様は実に学的でね、仏教の最初法院っていうのがあるわね。諸業行業無上処法無が一切区所の
4つの4
つの意味を含んでないお経は偽物だって言っ仏教自体がその
つが入ってる。入ってないといけない。諸業
無常というのは全てが変化する。
これが所無上処法無がというのはその変化
には法則がある。法則はもう決まってる
から変化の法則は自分の都合よく自分の
思うようにはできないよと。これが無がね
。ガではないんだ。この無ガがクになった
の。食うというのは無がだから空っぽと
いう意味じゃない。あのいかにもそのクー
という文字があれに見えるわね。空っぽに
見える。あれは中国語役であってな。どう
しても分からんやったらパリーを見てみろ
よ。そのぐらいのことはしてから文句言え
よね。誰かの役したそれがあっとるかどう
かも分からずにそいつを読んでそれを自分
が覚えてその人の知識を自分の知識と
勘違いしちまってそこまではまだいいとし
てもそんな変ない中途半端ないい科学的な
もので人に文句を言うとは何事じゃ?それ
はバカと言うんやねん。
仏教についてもちょっと言っとこうかね。
お釈迦様は王族地方の王様のところに
生まれて大津番の頭はものすごい天才やな
。嫁さんは綺麗。息子は優秀贅沢はできる
。もうあと何を望むんや。それで完全に
満足するはずやないか。それなのにどうし
ても区が残る。深い観がどうしても残る。
どうしたらその不快感が取れるだろうな
だろうと考えてウパ西哲学に頼ってあれを
したんだ。修行をした森へ入ってね。で、
ウパニシャド哲学では精神はいいんだけど
肉体が悪いんだと。だからその肉体を死ぬ
寸前までに至らしてみようと精神が勝つ
から雲消えるで本当に死ぬ寸前まで肉体を
いじめて修行して苦業っていうんやね。3
年やったかなんかやってみたけど全然クは
消えない。そこがあれは科学的な人なんや
ね。あ、こんなことしててもダメなんやと
。結局ウパニシャド哲学は間違っとるんだ
と。で、ともかく森から出てあんまり痩せ
とるもんでそばを通りかかった女の子が
お粥を食わしてくれた。それスジャータ。
昔スジータというあれがあったやろ。
コーヒーに入れるミルクがあったね。それ
を食わしてくれて、まず体力を回復して、
それから2川という川のそばの五大樹の
根元に座って瞑想を始めたんだね。そこで
1週間で下脱したんだ。全て分かった。で
、これが仏教になって
。まず分かったのが区は重要である。区は
善である。区というものは区で行動する。
行動したら目的を達成できる結果が出る。
結果ができた時に区が消えるで幸福になる
。これが値半ということだ。だけども最初
にその修行しようと思ったように記煙区が
あるやないか。どうしてその区が消えない
のか。これを消さんと意味がないわけやね
。これは間違った区なんだと。間違った
精神がである。だからくになればいい無が
。その間違った区を全部集めてみたら
シハクになった。シックは間違った区から
それをなくせばいい。それをなくす方法は
空になればいい。ガから生じた区だから空
になればその区は消える。だからそのシ
ハックで行動したって結果は出ないんだ。
絶対に結果出ない。間違っとんだから。だ
から雲も消えないし幸福にもなれないな。
も捨てっちまえということでね。正しい国
しようよと。そのシハックで行動しとる。
これがリン廻転んだ。覚めよっとるやろ。
やってもやってもだめや。だからリ廻転象
を切ると銀検証から外れると平和になっ
ちまう。値半弱場になるということやね。
さっき言った司法院の中で3番目、一切
回く。これを読み間違えて世の中全て苦な
んだというなあ。そういう暴さがおるや
ないか。これが言語で呼んでらんパーリー
語で。あれはね、一切
行くと書いてあるんや。結局行というのは
変化やね。行動も変化だから。行動も変化
やろ。だから全ての変化行動は区が起こさ
せるということなん。区が行動を起こさ
せる。だから区は善なんだ。区がないと
行動しない。行動しないと人間は生きて
いけない。進歩もしない。それをな役だけ
呼んどるもんだよ。
人生は苦であるなんて言い出すわけやないか。分からんやったらおかしいなと思ったら元に戻ってみよう。ましたら簡単なことやないか。
1点質問いいですか?はい。
この人なりの役だとクが空っぽで廻天が生まれ変わりみたいな。この人も何かしら本を読んでこうやって文句を言ってると思うんですよ。これは本が間違ってるってことです。
そうです。まず考えんといかんのは大丈夫教は間違いやないの?お釈迦んでお経かんやったろ。
お釈迦様の書いたお経なんて1つもないん
や。で、その時にね、こういうこと言っ
とるわ。自分が言ったから信用しなくても
よろしいと。偉い暴さが言ったから信用し
なくてもえ、やってみろと。自分の言う
通りのことをそうなるから科学やろ。
お釈迦様は最初から科学を目指しとるもん
で下手に自分がお経を書くと偏が
出来上がっちまうん。それを見て
しのしの子のと偉そうなことを言って
挙げ句の果てはそのお経を変えてな境を
作るようなやつが続くぞく現れるんだ。
大体主催っていうのはそういうものに自分
では天才じゃないからな。自分では作れん
けども天才の作ったやつを読んで自分が
天才になった気になっちゃうという。これ
が偏差修やないか。だからそれを防ぐため
にお経かんやったの。ただし行動しろと。
その行動の仕方の基本だけはうるさく言っ
とるんだ。どれが少年、少年1つやってみ
てごらん
。これね、コロナが流行っとる時にうちの
支援者の1人がコロナにかかった。今から
2週間入院をしますと。で、2週間という
時間がもったいないからベッドの上に
寝取るだけではその間になんかやれること
があったら教えてくださいっていうメール
が来たんや。でね、少年をやれ、少年やっ
てみる。ええ、練習になるから。そしたら
ね、女の子や彼女は食事の時にそれをやっ
たんだ。飯を食う時本人がびっくりしたん
や。なぜかと言うと病院食っていうのは
まずいものの代表じゃない。その病院食
入院食やな。それを少年で食べると非常に
満足感が得られる。食べたというね。どう
してでしょう?これは少年というのは
正しい行動をすることない。正しい行動の
ことを義って言うんだよ。人義霊地真の義
、正義の義。食事の目的は1つは
エネルギーやね、動くため、運動のための
エネルギー、もう1つは栄養やね、体を
維持するための栄養。その2つが目的なん
だから病植というのはその2つを完全に
満たしとるんだ。だからそれをは少年
正しく食べると満足しちゃう。そうすとね
、俺がそれまでずっとこう1つ疑問に思っ
とったのは仏教の中の有名な言葉で我ただ
たるを知るという言葉があるね。あれ?
真ん中に口を書いて上に5か。これ割れだ
。こっちにユい。ただ下に足たる。こっち
に矢印知る我ただ樽を知る。素晴らしい
言葉やないか。ただしどうしたらそれが
できるんやろ。これね、あのさっき言った
江戸時代のねーマンの旅行の中に書いて
ある。なんで日本人はこんなに幸福に
なれるんや。ヨーロッパ人には決してでき
ない。なぜならばものすごい貧乏やないか
。ヨーロッパ人いのは物でしか幸せに
なれんのや。そうやろ。日本人っていうの
は行動で幸せになれるんや。だから金が
ないから食べ物が例え貧しくてもそれを
少年で食えば満足するんよ。仕事でも満足
する職人みたいな。どんなこといつも満足
できるしとるんや。金がなくても物がなく
ても。だから幸せないだったらさあ、我々
はそれできるようにしといた方がええよ。
今から日本がダメになっていくやろ。もう
ダメ。かなりダメになってきたやないか。
これが本当に潰れるぐらいダメになった時
にろなもの食えんようになっちゃうよ。
そんな時に栄養とカロリーさえ満たせば
幸福になれる方法を身につけとけば十分
耐えれるよ。これが日本人っていうのは
できるんだ。昔の日本人は今それができん
ようになっちまったんリベラルのおかげで
。
もう1
個今度はあの質問みたいなのが来てたんですけど、ま、クとは全てが移り変わるという意味なので悟って下列した状態がずっと永遠に続くということは考えられないんですがどう思いますかっていうのがあって
それは空者なしに諸業無上の方やろ全てが変化するあれはね日本だけやないんよそでも科学を目指す哲学者っていうのはみんな所業無上から始めるんよ全てが変化するでその変化の法則を見つけ出そうと
する。そうするとね、マルクスの時かな。
マルクスが全てが変化する。もうやっぱり
彼もそれから始めとるんや。そしたらば
それを聞いた人がマルクスの弁償法。これ
は正しいって言っとるんや。マルクスはね
。その弁償法からいろんなあれを導き出し
とるんやけど、そのマルクスの弁償法を
変化するのか。そしたらやっぱりああいう
共産主義者ずるいからね。マルクスの弁償
法だけは変化しないんだって言ってる。
そんなバカなことない。あれはね、情報は
変化しないそうやろ。情報は変化せんやん
。今の一部をパッと切り取ってそこにこう
いう風ですよって言っとるだけの話であっ
て、そのもの自体はどんどん変化してても
切り取ったその部分を変化せんやろ。だ
から情報は変化せんのだからそこまで
なかなか彼らは気が回らんのやな。